[Music]
dude all the six through nine year olds
were just
losing their crap in the theater when
this was happening like hey that was
kind of cool
like yeah that was kind of cool it's
like it could have been like janky
something i really appreciate here is
the use of realistic camera positions
you know to be completely honest i don't
know how they did that
thanks to skillshare for sponsoring this
video stick around to the end to see the
easiest way to expand your knowledge
hey what's up everyone welcome back to
another episode of visual effects
artists react there's a specific clip
from this episode that i'm very excited
to look at from my childhood are you
ready sam are you ready nico i'm excited
for a couple of these clips we're
looking at some
really classic clips here plus some new
stuff and we got some
kind of stuff too we don't like to talk
poorly
about artists here but it's always
enjoyable to look at a chunky clip and
be like
yeah that's rough makes us feel okay
about ourselves
it's morphing time
okay so this movie is called mighty
morphin power rangers it came out when i
was like six years old and it was like
my favorite movie now this is a big
climactic battle at the end of the movie
they have all the megazords coming in
and they film the whole thing
on a miniature set some of these
buildings are about like you know 10
12 feet tall pretty cool they're filming
on a miniature but putting cg into it
this miniature city's killer it's pretty
awesome
so many reflections are happening
they're the most chrome
of the beasts you want to probably know
why there's so many reflections because
reflections are easy to make look real
and lighting on non-reflective surfaces
is a lot harder it's a lot easier to
make a chrome ball look photorealistic
than it is to make a white ball look
no that's an interesting point and i
don't know how much that influenced
their decision to make them all chromed
out but
i imagine probably quite a bit
all right guys i've got a lock on the
ooms man whoa it's clearly just a little
video clip
stuck to the front of the model it pops
right there
and it's straight up is just like
literally a 2d cutout in a 3d you can
tell it's a plane because there's a
little gap at the top of it or doesn't
quite reach the roof of the ship so it's
basically just a digital tv screen
the pop is really bugging me now where
i'm like they're like sir it pops it's
like we don't care
the aerial vehicles in this are pretty
good though because there's
just minimal animation on them there's
some pretty convincing shots at least
considering how limited they were back
then i'm impressed with what they were
able to achieve
they actually have the plate photography
of the cameras going through the city
you know these days
that would be just completely computer
generated but you have like this really
cool atmospheric effect when you capture
it in camera like this
and they're basically just compositing
the falcon into the scene like look at
that the lighting is pretty great
yeah oh he's using the tower as a weapon
so a little problem i noticed there is
his hand holding onto the post doesn't
stick to it and that's probably because
back then they didn't have an animation
system to
pin the post to his hand and some guy
trying to animate the post
and the hand frame by frame to line up
but they don't quite because he have to
just do it by hand you can't just click
a button and have the computer attach an
arm to the pole
yeah they don't have those animation
systems yet dude i still have that
problem when i animate stuff
you're this gorilla kong dude
uh he's the hand and i become the nuts
those gears inside the robots maybe
enough
like cgi budget for two gears inside the
robot
dude i remember loving this so much i
thought there's so much cool detail and
now i'm just like wow there were
literally two gears and a spring
yeah dude all the six through nine year
olds were just losing the crap in the
theater when this was happening
like everyone was just chugging apple
juice they're throwing it it's great
pizzas for everyone
hey wait that's good animation suddenly
look at that yeah that looks really good
that's like motion capture like that is
not hand animated
no look at it look at that it's so well
done every animation i've ever seen from
this era looks like
booty and that suddenly got the most
natural organic fluid motion i've ever
seen
yeah that's that's that's animated by
hand yeah i think not
yeah you can run but you
can't hide okay we're now at hand
animation again see
see how suddenly it looks like hand
animation i do see what you're talking
about yeah
it's night and day how did they get the
role so smooth
i feel like there was something where
they use photo reference or footage
just like the older animation techniques
in certain disney movies where they
would film someone dancing
and then effectively trace over it it
must have been reference
and just really animating to reference
oh no i want to give a big shout out to
all the people who spent
late nights getting that original power
rangers movie out because
it was so hype in those theaters when i
was eight yeah
so all you parents out there who took
your kid to see this movie and you're
just like ugh the things i do for my
kids
thank you thank you it's morphin time
do it better than anybody ever seen so
in 2017 they made
another power rangers movie man look how
far we've come
yeah and so now obviously we're having
all of the modern day visual effects
that you've come to get used to like
destruction
rubble smoke fire motion blur
the thing is this is all hand animated
too there might be a little bit of
motion capture for the big guy but
probably not this is probably still all
just animators doing their thing but
it's worth mentioning if there's an
animator in 1995 that's good they've
been doing it for
two years three years four years max and
now yes some of you could have been an
animator for 25 years
something i'm now realizing again that i
really appreciate here is the use of
realistic camera positions it's the same
sort of thing that made specific tim
so great pacific rim
worked really well because it always
felt like the scale worked you know
you're seeing it from the ground you're
seeing it from inside a cockpit and you
don't have any of these
really fast moving cameras
look at that freaking molten sword came
out and blew through a building and
that's pretty sweet that's a great angle
for it and everybody's moving slowly
which is what they should be doing
so gigantic and back in the day when
they'd filmed people in rubber suits
doing the fights they'd film them in
slow motion so they looked big and
they're staying true to that
they're using the dirty lens effect all
over the place here that technically
would imply that there's a camera
in this scene filming it does that
immerse you more or does it pull you out
i think it in this situation immerses me
more because it feels like every time
i'm seeing something it feels like i'm
actually seeing it from an actual
position
but by that statement each time you see
like glow or
bloom on an image you're like i'm not
immersed anymore because i can tell that
bloom is happening from lens artifacting
it's the whole thing of like sometimes
you do visual effects not to make it
look real
but to make it look how it would look if
you did it practically but it was still
a movie well yeah because this entire
sequence
is entirely computer generated the whole
town is computer generated so they have
to
add as many lens tricks as they can to
kind of help make you think that this is
real you've talked about that before
it's like
we're not trying to make reality we're
trying to make hollywood reality what
have we come to expect
when we see these movies i've gone back
and forth on this one a lot and
i've come out on the other side of it
going it's good i would recommend giving
the power rangers movie
uh a look if you skipped over it today
we're doing something very special
it's a special occasion we are not going
to ask you to subscribe
instead feel free to check out corridor
digital.com and maybe sign up for a
membership we have all our videos there
ad free exclusive shows it's great it's
a cool place some say
cooler than youtube and if you don't
want to pay for the subscription guess
what you get a free trial
this is such a cool scene you've seen
power rangers and your father's like
all right we're leveling up you want to
see a cool movie and you're like all
right now you're like 10 and you're like
okay
let's do this
i remember being terrified of these
blades i remember this cave as like a
place
like when i think about this scene in
that cave i know where that is
it's a matte painting with the miniature
in the foreground and then a little
thing on the top
beautiful i know they did a lot of
really cool matte paintings in this
movie
so how do you guys think they did this
shot um well that's projection mapping
but how would they have done that
projection mapping back then
what if it's just a practical set
like they actually this is practical
that's practical except it's a miniature
so they filmed harrison ford on a blue
screen but what you're seeing there in
the background it's a miniature and they
literally painted that bridge
so that it blended in and you couldn't
see it until the camera moved oh i'm
seeing the wobbly feet now
i'm seeing the blue screen tracking is
that film jitter yeah it's that film
jitter but you know
no one cares because they're looking at
this crazy optical illusion yeah
at the time it's like how the heck are
you going to projection map
anything there's no such thing but that
being said it's like
that is still projection mapping you
know it's the same thing when you see
like artists doing chalk drawings on the
street and it's only an image when you
view it from the right angle but when
you get up and standing on top of the
chalk drawing is a stretched thing
oh dude which cup it's gonna be which
one was jesus's cup
she's like you should pick this fancy
gold one jesus would
drink out of this one he would slurp out
of this
[Music]
oh oh cool dude his hair growing like
that
[Applause]
oh wow god what a shot well right off
the bat that hair growing
i know how they did that one that's easy
it's actually really easy to tell if you
look at the background
yes it's reversed footage they start out
with the hair
outside and then they pull it through
the head of the model then they
play that back and it looks like it
grows and it's funny they didn't even
bother to hide
the flames in the background going the
wrong way watch the fire you can see the
fire burn backwards
that's great that's great that's a fun
little detail so but then it comes to
this
you know to be completely honest i don't
know how they did that it's definitely
done
stop motion there's no stop motion in
this whoa
like look at the suit the suit ages and
blackens and
begins shredding i'm totally right the
suit is stop motion
i'll give you that much if you watch his
jaw on the left there and you watch
closely you'll get some
digital artifacts happening that maybe
can help cue you in
a little bit are we seeing morphs you
are seeing some more
okay so i imagine that they probably
created
four different practical heads and
each head is going through the same
motions and then they're
overlaying those and cutting between
them and then morphing between them you
got it you nailed it they built an
animatronic
dude and they programmed his motions for
the entire performance
they have it animated so like they have
stuff on the inside that can pull the
nose back and pull the eyes back and
stuff
and it goes as far as it can and they
take that latex head they make a mold of
it
make a new head mess it up even more
stick it onto the same animatronic so
it's all motion controlled the
animatronics doing the exact same
performance every time then all they're
doing is picking the end of when you
want to see one
animatronic head and morphing it into
the next one but how did they get the
skin to like literally boil and crumple
like that that's actually practical what
they did is they had like an underlying
skull and they put plastic that strings
under heat
on top of that skull and they took
styrofoam cups melted them down using a
solvent and then painted that over it to
give it like a skin layer and then they
blast it with heat that shrink wrap
plastic
shrinks and it pulls all the skin with
it creating the effect of all the skin
getting peeled back from the skull wow
that must have taken a long time to do
the moment you start filming it to the
time you're done is like weeks
potentially you know like we talked
about motion control of cameras we can
replicate the same camera motion so you
can like comp two people in the shot but
imagine doing motion control for a
character so the character is doing the
exact same actions
so you can blend between different
states of that character and have it
line up visually and not have any issues
it's one of those things where you watch
it you're like i don't know how they did
it it's a magic trick
and i love those kind of visual effects
moments all right so this is a
bad effect shot that was recommended to
us in the comments so if you guys
good effect shots bad effect shots you
know the drill leave a comment
it really helps us out in picking out
shots for the show whatever happens next
it's on you so all i know about the
order is that it's about werewolves but
i guess there's not a lot of werewolves
in it sorry spoilers there's also the
end of the season so whatever
okay here we go he's getting snapped
okay okay so some some particles so far
it's pretty cool it's kind of aging you
can see his face get gray
wait that was it that was it that was it
that's the finale that's that's the big
moment
hey that's kind of cool yeah that was
kind of cool it's like you could have
thought that like yeah like obviously
this isn't like avengers like endgame
snapping kind of stuff and obviously
that's the best crumbling slash person
dissolving effect of all time i'm
defending this
i'm putting my foot down i'm on board
with that it doesn't make me go oh
look i know what button they press to
get that effect which is usually
when you see a bad effect it's like this
default setting but you look at this and
it's like you know the turbulence
isn't half bad it's it's pleasing to
watch especially when his shoulder first
starts disappearing there
you can actually like really see the
turbulence causing it to chip away and
fly away in come on that's not bad you
guys are right it's not
the worst effect in the world or
anything like that my biggest critique
of the shot is where
his body is melted away he's just a
floating head but it's just still locked
to space as he's still standing there
just makes it feel pretty flat and like
something's just dissolving the footage
with particle effects on the side of it
i actually enjoy looking at it i enjoy
watching it mostly for the particles
yeah i like particles and i like fluid
mechanics me too i
i could go for a good particle sim
anytime
[Music]
this is one of the strangest videos
we've done such a good video
[Music]
this is when ren unlocked how to do
really really amazing smoke simulations
octane had literally just released the
ability to render out
volumes like smoke and fire we're like
what can we do with this this is like
brand new we don't know what to do
vape god
[Music]
look like jake as an adult farmer this
crops are dying
here comes the vape god to make new
clouds
rain look at like the holy vape that he
[Music]
has
that plant growing looks great though
the little snaps that it does and it
pops up
that's just straight up after effects
dude that's a 2d image that you yeah it
was just 2d images
oh i took a hit from the holy vape man i
died i'm very proud of that shot
that yeah that looks great transition
shot just literally a 2d image of nico
is tracked into that shot
[Music]
dude i love staying with the vape that
you have that you pass it to him it
becomes
giant
[Music]
dude in this shot right here oh amazing
so this whole camera move here nico's
not there but you tracked him into the
shot
yeah and used that as like a bit of a
subtraction mask for the smoke
when he's first going out not the
two-door on horns you know but like
two-two
on vapes yeah but it's pretty good what
a ridiculous video that's it
four and a half years ago holy time
flies you know what's funny and
satisfying is when you release a video
years ago and you're like i didn't get
that many views and then you
just wait a casual five years and it has
eight million views now and you're like
ah it did well
you know what that video eventually
lived up to my expectations
so guys tomorrow a video is coming out
that i'm very very happy with it's this
brand new camera that's incredibly
lightweight in fact it's so lightweight
that for the first time
ever we're able to put an hd high
quality camera on the back of a falcon
really really awesome looking footage
really cool opportunity and that video
comes out tomorrow subscribe so that you
do not miss out so we are all about
learning on this channel because we
ourselves are always learning
and if you're looking for a place that's
focused on learning you should check out
skillshare they have classes in pretty
much
everything whether you want to learn how
to cook better write better
draw better make videos better or just
be at peace with yourself better they
have
lessons from all types of different
individuals for all types of different
individuals for example a lot of people
rent apartments
skillshare has a featured class right
now on interior design parenters it's
called reversible interior design
the whole point is is when you move into
a place you're going to want that
security deposit back so how do you go
about doing interior design in a way
that's non-destructive it's a pretty
cool concept for a class to be taught
about interior design and it's a good
demonstration of
all the crazy different types of classes
and knowledge that skillshare has to
offer most classes are under 60 minutes
so those lessons will fit into any
schedule and it's less than 10
a month with an annual subscription so
whether you're a working professional
looking to hone your skills or just
somebody looking to find a new hobby
skillshare has a whole variety of
classes
just for you so go check them out the
first 1 000 people to click the link in
the description below will get 30
off of an annual premium membership if
you've already used a free trial you can
still use this deal as well
all right back to the end of the video
every sunday we do a visual effect of
our
own which gives us the right to come
here sit down and roast
these clips if you want to see these vfx
that we're doing and judge for yourself
whether or not we're qualified to do
this show subscribe and watch our videos
every sunday wait we do other things on
vfx i know people are always like ah
they only ever do vfx artists react and
it's like no
we do a lot of other stuff we've been
putting cameras on random things for
years